welcome back to the rock stars and with
Kang the Conqueror making his fearsome
debut in the Ant-Man and the Lost
quantumania trailer of massively
minuscule proportions we know that a
microverse Invasion could very well come
to the regular-sized people of the MCU
but what if I told you Kang's Army
wasn't your average alive person Army
what if I told you that Kang was
building a diseased Army of the Dead to
invade the Multiverse this is Rogue
Theory the show where we pitched the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is Mt going wrong
with me today is King the conquerors
accomplice before he stabbed her in the
back like the jerk that he is is Jessica
Clemens what's going on Jess
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jess you're so cute right now I really
just like I wanna I wanna hug your whole
body like with including your head in
the little Hood you're just adorable
like I would love a plush of like just
that I'm just Jess and a hoodie
like a little Jessica stuffed animal in
her little Hood you guys uh add new rock
stars epic hero shop maybe they can make
yeah
I like it I'm here for it it receives my
full vote 10 out of 10. and my goodness
we have many
herself in the building it is Whitney
van laningham what's going on Whitney ah
so much Quantum stuff I'm so small you
guys don't know it but I'm actually only
this [ __ ] this recording has blown me
up with the with the machine that Willy
Wonka used to stretch out Mike TV that's
right that's the only reason I'm able to
be here today and the true inventor of
the pin particle do not believe the
propaganda it's Tom Michaelson this is
true I don't know if you guys saw me in
end game
um you all I thought it was Michael
Douglas but it was really me with those
that long long flowing locks holding the
little wrist it's true it was I was the
one actually mixing the camera I had the
beaker and everything and I was mixing
that and he just answered the phone and
ran off seriously he got all the credit
but what a jerk thank you for finding it
so thank you for finally letting the
people know who the real hero of the MCU
is the rat and me who made the pin
particle I right guys it's time for our
first Rogue topic of today I missed you
guys Mike I I first of all thank you to
Whitney for for the amazing impression
of me
for Halloween it was made my entire week
I missed you guys so much I never want
to take another vacation again because
it keeps me from you empty I was
literally wearing that the shirt you are
wearing today is the one I would
continuity is important to me all right
now our first topic for today
um yes I believe that came the Conqueror
in the quantum realm once Scott's Lane
to steal the quantum virus from one if
to build a zombie army because I don't
know if you guys remember from uh what
if but like Janet Van Dyne uh she got a
she's the one who introduced that whole
zombie threat to the entirety of the MCU
um when when Hank brought her back to
the big regular people verse so I think
that this Quantum virus also exists in
the live-action Universe to some degree
we just don't know where it is we don't
know how Janet contracted that virus in
the the what if universe so I'm thinking
that it actually exists somewhere maybe
it's being kept under lock and key and
like they have to do a heist to get it
but I think that Kang the Conqueror over
once Scott Lang to steal this virus so
that he can
um conquer a lot easier and just build a
zombie army and uh so zombies can Nom
Nom on people and make more zombies yeah
that's how zombies work I've heard yeah
that's how zombies are made when a mommy
Daddy bites a dad
a baby zombie is born
exactly yeah if they don't eat if they
don't eat that the other person they bit
but yes exactly yes yes I freaking love
this and if this now it's like if this
isn't what they're doing I feel like I
don't know that just the steak seems so
high with that that's why that seems
like such an awesome idea and and you're
exactly right and what if when Hank went
back to go get Janet she was already
infected with with that Quantum virus or
whatever they they want to call it that
made people zombies and if and I've
always said if they're not going to you
know if there's if it's not going to be
talked about in Ant-Man 3 because it has
to do with the quantum realm they're
gonna be bringing back live action
Marvel Zombies somehow maybe in like
they're saving it for like an Avengers
movie maybe for Kang Dynasty yeah maybe
when he actually gets to weaponize them
or maybe in secret Wars is one of the
variants they have to fight and that
would also be a really fun way to bring
back some of these a-listers who have
maybe you know put down put down the
mantle like Chris Evans could come back
and just be a zombie just for an
afternoon without ruining what he's done
with cap or RDJ even for Iron Man so
that's freaking awesome and I love that
idea and how cool would it be to see a
Quantum out of the minivans and all
these zombies
tearing up people that would be freaking
zombie that'd be cool that's what I was
I want to see I want to come back dude
he was the first he was the first victim
in the Ant-Man version right right
to come back to attack Hydra for killing
him because my God what jerks what jerks
I can't even believe and then all the
other ants at the seagulls ate and uh
Ulysses has Grant and all the other ones
or whatever they can all come back but
that would be that would be freaking
awesome and amazing if if it was the
zombies which is what was at the core of
all of this I love it that's great
thanks man what what do the ladies think
zombies
oh so where is the virus being stored
exactly do you think that it's just like
it's like in Osmosis Jones you know when
there's just like viruses that are
almost in the body system or is it like
or is it like there's like a lab where
Kang has been managed like the CDC in
World War Z where all the viruses are
stored underground yeah
storage facility maybe yeah like is it
that like is somebody making these
viruses or are the viruses just like
that's just something you can get in the
quantum realm so it's floating around
and contagious I I have a feeling that
um Bill Murray's character whoever he's
playing has that
um he would be the guy yeah and like um
um Jenna Van Dyne has a past
relationship with this man because she's
been in this Quantum realm for God knows
how long I don't know how time works in
the quantum Realms like she could be
like a bazillion years old I don't know
um but I think that at one Point she had
a relationship of either business or
close relationship and she knows that
um and Kang knows that she's like the
best way to get to this virus
um because like she just knows the lay
of like wherever he lives and like and
she's like all right Scott you're the
heist man you're the only one that can
get this because I don't know why I
can't
um I don't know I have to work out
um I have creatine to consider
you know um idea I'm gonna put a a hat
on a hat a theory on a theory What If
part of this is because we know the
comics that King you know
um uh Kang's love is Ravenna rensslayer
maybe in this Dimension with the king of
the Conqueror she's died and he's he
needs to and Bill Murray had a way to
bring her back and accidentally created
this Quantum virus thing and that's what
kind of Spurs off Kang's story in
general and the zombie story in general
because uh it I I imagine that you know
no one would want to create this Undead
Army of you know people eaters but uh
but that that's how they could tie into
Kang's history too in the comics uh in
some ways having it be maybe she's gone
here and he's trying to bring Ravenna
rensslayer back
um you guys I
was saying Bill Murray
his character's name is
Bill Murray got stuck in the quantum
realm and somehow contracted a zombie
virus and then when Bill Murray dated
Janet Van Dyke
maybe they'll just Star Wars eyes his
name where they change it and make it
sound like a name of sarceo his name
would be like bile marappa or something
like that yeah
that's how they'll do it they'll just
make it sound like a fantasy name but
then that would also mean that Janet Van
Dyne got to date younger hotter
Ghostbusters Bill Murray before he was a
huge major [ __ ] was Bill Murray ever
attractive
like he's just like a regular white man
I don't know he was just very yeah he's
a very average looking white man but he
was he was hot he's a hot commodity in
the 80s what can I think it was just so
funny but young him is still he's a very
problematic dude
BM you're problematic hate to be the one
to have to call you out on your sorry
Bill
sorry Bill sorry Bill well we're not
sorry you did it no we're not sorry he
did the bad things we're not sorry to
him you're not much more like excited to
bust you out but sorry not sorry that's
what it is sorry not sorry Bill yes you
[ __ ] I have a feeling that he
will not be uh in any other MCU movie
after this I don't know who knows it's
clear in the trailer they like took away
all his dialogue
like he's here I guess and moving on
yeah so what do you think Jess I think
it's fun I think it's Rogue I love any I
uh anyway to bring anyone back uh and
this seems like a fun way to bring
people back yes yeah bring people from
the dead I just had a weird idea while
we were talking about this what if this
zombie virus was an attempt was
engineered for the purposes of like
these tiny um subatomic people to take
over the bodies of a bigger person like
a Mech it's like okay look at those big
people let's take over their body so we
can have a Mech so that we can just
fight
um a war from like from down here but
like have them kill each other I don't
know yeah like a little like almost like
men in black with the little aliens
inside the suit except that it's a
little person and it could be like
what's this voice it's like it's your
conscience like that man Civil War and
you wouldn't even know because they're
miniature yeah exactly I think it'd be
really fun if like zombies were being
like even though like from the human
perspective it's like oh my God it's
like it's a crazy zombie but like
they're the zombies were moving
purposefully because they were being
controlled by like little tiny people
it's like yeah kill all the humans we're
gonna take over the we're gonna send
wait so so are we now imagining that all
of the zombies are only this big when
they come out of the quote
is that what we're saying so like would
you like
zombies
and the van doors open but instead of
regular-sized zombies it's just a little
mini zombies and they go around and they
give you little mini zombie bites that
would be hilarious very deadly way more
deadly than full-size zombies hey all
you gotta do by one person and then like
you you got a big yeah just like a tiny
guy all you have to do you show up to
one picnic you'll take the whole family
exactly yeah like my God I'm a whole
meal
yeah it would take so many bites to turn
me
[Laughter]
so do you see the Marvel Studios
um bringing in the zombies live action
Marvel zombies at some point in the
future it's too much of an iconic Marvel
staple and like you know um especially
with the success of werewolf by night I
feel like Marvel now knows that people
have a demand for like the darker
um more like you know Supernatural
bloodier and gorgeous
zombie strange out here just Paving
exactly like I'm telling you that's
right I honestly do think that that
zombie strange is gonna come back as Mr
Misery to start some he was [ __ ] cool
I want him back and even though he's a
he's an undead but dead body I mean he's
not really a zombie right because it's
strange like uh you know uh you know
hijacking yeah yeah exactly he's not
like he doesn't have the hunger or
anything so anything it's almost like
he's like the day Walker of zombies uh
you know so maybe that strange would be
in the blade movie you know that right
zombie strange I I do love that for him
to be a new character yeah dig it I like
that I take it but yeah okay so wrapping
up this first topic what do you guys
think overall do you guys think that
this idea of of Kang himself wanting
Scott to steal the quantum virus
um to start a zombie invasion do you
guys think it's rogus do you guys think
it's bogus or do you guys think it's the
middle Jess patented ogus
glad I created something for this
icon she is the pro Queen
um
when the hood comes on the baby talk
comes out
he's like man okay
Tracy villain say so come on
I'm gonna give it a rogus because it is
very Rogue it's very Rogue
um and the whole point of Rogue theory
is to make that chick crazy and I think
this is crazy
well thank you Jess I appreciate that I
will take your rogus and keep it forever
thank you Jess what do you guys think
man
I'm also I'm also gonna give it a rogus
but in addition to my rogus is gonna be
a little tiny zombie guy right on top of
the figure because okay because I vote I
vote yes and I also vote that we get
small tiny zombies
tiny zombies please
give us both give us full size give us
tiny we only saw one tiny zombie and
what if when we saw Janet van died so
like just make 14 zombies more times
yeah the first zombie we ever saw was
Tiny exactly
Nations I already Cannon tiny zombies
trademark I'm gonna give it a rogus and
two yeah that's because that was great
that was that I'm like I said I'm gonna
be I'm kind of it's one of those where
I'm like [ __ ] I know this is Rogue
Theory and it's supposed to be kind of a
little bit out there but that's so crazy
it just might work and now I'm gonna be
a little bummed if we don't really kind
of get that I'm sure Quantum meaning is
gonna be cool I'm sure it's gonna be
fine but uh we we and like like you said
empty we know that they've got to be
coming in some way or fashion some movie
and whether it's this one or yeah as
some weapon that someone uses later in
one of the Avengers movies uh uh I'll
take it either way but I would love to
see this movie be about trying to steal
that virus and have it be like a Marvel
World War Z movie or something that
would be legit let's go I would love it
I would love it all right thank you guys
dude I've missed this so much I'm so
glad to do another Rogue Theory to
introduce another Rogue Theory topic to
you guys but up next even more
importantly Jess has an amazing Theory
coming up but first be sure to head on
over to new rockstarsmerch.com where you
can get some awesome new channel merch
that just dropped including a limited
edition new rockstars enamel pin each
one is individually numbered which you
know makes it collectible there's a
limited number so grab one super fast
you can check out all the awesome merch
options available at new
rockstarsmerch.com today tomorrow and
forever but we also we want to thank
iconic cocktail for sponsoring this
video podcast sometimes after a long day
of coming up with perfect theories I
like to kick back and enjoy a refreshing
cocktail but I can get tired of the same
old boring rum and soda that's where
iconic cocktail comes in iconic cocktail
makes all natural mixers and sodas for
cocktails all their products are made
with real ingredients by real bartenders
for really easy to make drinks they're
the ideal ingredient for the perfect
cocktail or mocktail their website
iconiccocktail.com is loaded with easy
to search recipes as well as tips and
tricks to add a little Spirit to your
home bar you can follow their simple
method for three-step cocktails or
explore over 150 unique recipes other
ingredients are fresh and flavorful and
they release new seasonal flavors year
round they're never too sweet because
they cut back on sugar to focus on
Flavor plus they ship coast to coast and
make a great gift we tried their Copper
State Mule cocktail using their ginger
syrup in the office and it was a
smashing success producer Zach
particularly loves the Desert Blossom
cocktail made with a spiced honey we
can't wait to try more discover some new
cocktails for yourself and add a little
spirit for your next drink by visiting
iconiccocktail.com and use promo code
new rockstars to get 20 off your order
visit iconic cocktail.com for recipes
education and more and use promo code
new rockstars to get 20 off your order
and we also want to thank pharity for
sponsoring this podcast because if
you're looking to up your wardrobe game
this fall then pharity has got you
covered with clothes which cover your
body parody is all about clothing for
life's best moments they make clothes
that feel good and make you feel good
parody is a family brand that believes
comfort and quality are key they're
passionate about craftsmanship
sustainability and making clothes that
look and feel great every piece is
designed to be a lifetime favorite in
fact the clothes get even better with
age and if anything happens along the
way Verity will replace or fix your
clothes for life no matter what they're
committed to you layer your favorite
pieces for a cozy fall Vibe they've got
tons of options for women and men your
desk to find a new fall favorite at
Verity producer Brandon loves his soft
and stretchy Legend sweater shirt from
Verity he literally can't stop talking
about it I cannot wait to meet him so I
can just feel the fabric of that sweater
shirt because my God I'm tired of
hearing about it honestly you just
really never stop talking about it right
now ferret is giving all Rogue Theory
fans 15 off of every order you heard me
you get 15
off your order had to brand.com Rogue
Theory and use code Rogue Theory at
checkout to get this deal that's code
Rogue Theory at Verity
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com for 20 off
veritybrand.com Rogue Fury all right
Jessica
I have missed you in your Rogue theories
please take it away for the second topic
of the day I think in secret Invasion
that Clint Barton is gonna die oh and
this is the reason why I think he's
gonna die I don't hope he dies but I
think he's gonna die
um I don't hope anyone in the MCU ever
actually dies except for maybe Johnny
mayonnaise but regardless
he's gonna be a first to go
so I think that Clem Barton is going to
die in secret Invasion and I don't want
him to die but he probably will and I I
have reasoning behind why I think he's
gonna die so I know the secret invasion
is supposed to be a mini TV series but I
think that that situation we've been
ramping up to for a long time with being
like who's a scroll where is the scroll
how are the Scrolls they're a squirrels
so we're trying to figure out who's a
scroll in the MCU right now and in the
comics there is uh the comic secret
invasion was a really big storyline to
even like they were like they'd killed
like one major person that was like
Janet Van Dyne because they were trying
to recreate her entirely so they were
just like let's just get rid of her
right now in this series and we'll redo
something and go back into the past in
another storyline so I think that one
person is going to be Clint Barton and I
think Clint Barton is a good person to
kind of redo not redo but get rid of and
explore more of what he has to offer
within his family within Linda
Cardellini his wife and with Kate Bishop
in passing that mantle on because I
think all the Marvel Avengers are now
passing the mantle and I think he needs
to pass the mantle more so than retiring
because we all know he never really goes
into retirement so
I think what's gonna happen is in secret
Invasion we're gonna fail because we
already said allegedly know that Linda
Cardellini his wife's character is uh
Mockingbird so I think and Mockingbird
was a big part of the comic she turned
into a scroll she infiltrated the West
Coast Avengers she was a [ __ ] I love
her to death I don't stand by her in
every form even in even in Vision Quest
I was like I feel it I get it
Mockingbird so I think she's gonna
become she's gonna actually be a scroll
and what we saw last of her in Hawkeye
and uh and Hawkeye she was still a
scroll I think she is a scroll he
brought her the watch she said oh thanks
and so I think she's infiltrating she'll
be a scroll and then from Hawkeye to
what we've seen secret Invasion he'll be
like you are a squirrel this entire time
go crazy and fight her and kill her but
then also just go crazy on the rest of
the Scrolls and fight but he'll die in
the midst of the fight and Linda
Cardellini will approach and From the
Ashes come new life and she'll still be
alive but her husband will be dead and
Clint Barton will die
um those kids are gonna hate her yeah
that would uh start a strained
relationship for sure no more they're
gonna hate the scroll no more Mother's
Day cards that's for dang sure they're
gonna hate to scroll her and when she
dies she'll turn back into the scroll so
hopefully the kids will see but it also
gives reason to explore his daughter and
son I think his daughter is much more
than what we see and in Hawkeye this is
my makeup and in Hawkeye I wanted to see
what more she would give and she didn't
give enough and so I think her dad dying
is gonna start her hero's journey and
we're gonna see her turn into someone
interesting interesting I you that you
had like a couple theories in there it
was like not only is the Hawkeye going
to die but then uh mockingbird's a
skrull and all of that but I that's
really really fun and interesting if the
watch from Hawkeye just told the time on
uh the scroll home planet it's like oh
yeah it's just uh yeah
that's how we find out we see the watch
face and it's like wait a minute those
aren't Earth
[Applause]
Tommy Lee what does that mean yeah
exactly it's like don't worry about it
it's a shield watch right yeah yeah I
like this idea of you know obviously I I
do like Clint Barton I don't want him to
die but it seems like you know Clint
Barton's time in the MCU might be up in
terms of like
his story and like I don't know like I
just feel like it's it's time to pass
the mantle to to Kate Bishop
um not because I'm biased
um
[Music]
what do you have to say because I'm
gonna listen to what you have
I mean Kate Bishop would die but uh
goodbye Rogue Theory and she wouldn't
get out of bed for months he would not
be able to host this show anymore if I'm
sitting in the movie theater and I see
Kate Bishop die I'm going up to the
projector room and ripping the thing out
and throwing it to the streets because I
don't accept it I do not accept it if
she dies that this the screen protector
dies yes no I don't want that to happen
just for the record I'll just try that
I'm just trying to get a rise
but yeah yeah it worked oh it's easy
it's really easy yeah no this is really
great I really like it and I think you
know we know for a fact that the scrolls
are gonna have to have been here the
whole time and whether that's someone
like happy or you know even Nick Fury or
and having it be Mockingbird you know
having it be his wife is a really good
candidate because she's been there you
know know since almost since the get-go
in an age of Ultron and soda and so to
have her be part of it and also the
other thing too is we're missing because
in the secret Wars uh the secret
Invasion comic you know the uh the real
the person who kind of infiltrated
everything was Spider-Woman the squirrel
who took over kind of the Spider Woman
that Jessica Drew uh you know body so we
don't have her right now and secret
invasion's coming up and so they need
maybe maybe Mockingbird will be that
character that's been here the whole
time that's infiltrated that everybody
trusts and loves but really she's kind
of one of the big bads I really love
that idea on the break room yesterday we
pitched that she uh the Jessica Drew
does exist and when the uh when no way
home happened she ended up in our
timeline but she died in an alley in a
scrolls are and just took on her
appearance she was in her suit like I
thought she said the Spider Woman she
was like I'm gonna take that form yeah
yeah yeah
Hudson this girl is like is that Spider
Woman from the secret Invasion series
they put rocks in her pocket and just
threw her into her Lake I'll take that
one no one else has claimed this one
guys yeah all right I'm in you guys want
this body are you sure that's even a
super easy yeah
can we just take bodies of this
Dimension yeah I'll just get this one
hold on guys easy I'm gonna go dig up
Abraham Lincoln's corpse real quick
hopefully I'm still there let me know
that'd be so funny to appear as like
George Washington and then just be like
this guy right this guy you guys
remember everybody this guy no I want I
want the ship to open and all these
Heroes to come out and then have like
one of the random presidents like
Rutherford B Hayes and we're like who
the hell is this
yeah exactly who is this the other
scrolls are like I told you not to
choose a [ __ ] president dude
exactly they only know the last three
it's gonna be a slit band you own
Miranda here I would believe that one
more yeah
but it was Leslie Odom Jr that would be
great Miranda would be a really good
song have the Scrolls come on being like
I'm willing to wait for it
dude I I really like I really like this
Theory because
um I have been very convinced for a long
time that Ant-Man is gonna be the next
to die and I think that I'm more ready
for Clint Barton to die than I am for
Ant-Man to die I have this it's more
like anxiety like I just have this like
horrific anxiety that they're gonna pull
the death of Ant-Man at the end of
quantumania and just ice Paul Rudd and
he's so beautiful I don't want that to
happen but have you seen Kang's ABS
Kang's abs are more beautiful than the
entirety of Paul Rudd's existence
Avenger there's six of them for the
original six yeah exactly each AB is an
infinity stone
[Music]
and they're not abs
the stones
um but I I am more ready to to let Clint
go I don't want him to die ever
obviously I don't want anyone to die but
I would be more ready to say goodbye to
that character than to Ant-Man and uh so
this absolves my anxieties Jessica just
soothed in anxiety this was like a
little bar of Xanax for my brain now I'm
like okay Clint Barton could die that
sounds reasonable at least ant-man's not
yay so I like this series oh no I like I
think that I also think that Ant-Man is
about to die very soon I think that no
it's gonna be very sad but if Clint
Barton dies they can't kill both of them
they can't kill both of them so let's
just pretend let's just pretend it's
Clinton because that benefits I just
came down guys please
what do you guys think of this idea of
um Clint Barton's like the the new baby
the new Barton baby that came out um
after Age of Ultron uh what if that baby
was a scroll and like baby the real baby
was taken oh that would be okay oh so
that would be sick that would be sick
horrible so sick and horrible at the
same time because I like the idea
because in uh Miss Marvel and the comics
at least her family the real origin was
like it was squirrels that mixed with
humans so it I like the idea of Clint
Barn's wife actually being a scroll and
they had a baby together but it's like
where's the original Linda Cardellini
where's the where's the original one
when did you swap has it been forever or
has it not been because that's just like
complete he seems like such a family man
like a a on the on the ranch family man
that he would be like I don't care if
you I fell in love with you you're not
the person I loved and I'd be like okay
well it's the person you fell in love
with so deal with it but I think he
wouldn't be for it could you imagine if
she left if Linda cardellini's like um
I've heard of real Mockingbird was taken
over before end game so when the real
one comes back now she's gonna see
Mohawk tattoo end game
are you you know why are you wielding
around this bloody samurai sword yeah
yeah that would be hilarious no it would
be super crazy if like he just never
knew Mockingbird and like he just only
knew the scroll version of her yeah and
like that he's like I don't know you
Hawkeye I don't actually like you as a
person sorry it's almost like the Gamora
Star Wars thing looks like this guy yeah
I don't even know you yeah that would be
heartbreaking that would suck though and
I also I feel bad because like Clint
Barton has been through a lot so to have
his like real life come back and be like
I actually don't love you you love this
girl the whole time after losing Nat
no I would be so sad for him either I
can't trust any of these women I can't
trust him anymore
and that's how he turns he becomes the
Intelligentsia okay
let's vote on this like what do you guys
think of Jess's theory of uh Clint
Barton dying
um in secret Invasion do you guys think
it's rogus bogus or ogus or or togus
east togus I think it's rogus because I
do think that we are gonna see a major
like scroll reveal like that and why not
Linda Carter like it would make perfect
sense like this just kind of makes sense
so I I really like this Theory I think
it's good where the Rogue is from
Whitney what do you think Tom I'm gonna
do rogus too I'm gonna do rogus because
you know it's funny what you mentioned
too just about him uh he's not gonna
retire and in a weird way the Avengers
movies unfortunately have always nerfed
him or taken him out of the story only
to bring him back like even Avengers one
out the gate he was he was mind
controlled and not even really in the
movie and then in yeah and then he
retired after Ultron but they came back
for civil war and then he retired up
there and again they came back for this
and so I kind of feel like the only way
he's not going to be around is If he if
he bites the dust and so I think that
would be a crazy way to do it because
that would definitely be final because
with Clint Barton he always will come
back you know they've established he'll
always be back but maybe maybe not if he
uh if he dies
can't come back from being a dead guy
unless you come back as a dead guy but
that's a whole thing let's come back as
a dead guy as a time yeah
ladies and gentlemen that's what we call
him the comedy World a callback
the third time that'll be the rule of
three three let me tell you I spent
enough money on improv classes I
I'm also going to give this a rogus but
like slightly tipping to August slightly
no I don't care
[Music]
only because Hawkeye was not confirmed
for the series that's the only reason
why a lot of people aren't confirmed yet
this is true a lot of people are not
confirmed yet but like just because we
just pretty much only Mephisto confirmed
it it's true he who remains wasn't
confirmed in Loki and showed up at the
end y'all throw us all the loop so we
all know it's because of what we said
about hailee Steinfeld exactly
we already know I forgot about that
bogus yeah
he's like also be by local theater
beware I'm ripping off the projector I'm
gonna go find Haley Steinfeld and I'm
gonna go marry her and I'm gonna wave
that certificate in your face and it's
completely monogamous
the first row objective I'll say Haley
you're so beautiful sing to me I'd be
like Mary marry me instead oh my
goodness
he gets into a relationship I'm going to
be M.I.A for a month I'm gonna be crying
um
no I'm not all right now it's time for
our Rogue question are you guys ready
for this because weird the Al Yankovic
story is free to stream this weekend on
the Roku Channel what so what beloved
and kind Hollywood figure do you think
is due for a gritty roguish biopic this
is this is the first one that came to
mind but uh but um I
what if we had some nuts biopic movie
about Rick Moranis and where he went
after honey
and that explains his whole his whole
story of why he left Hollywood or what
he's been up to and it could be this
nuts over-the-top story that would be
you know it could involve car chases and
maybe uh the Yakuza and he could be it
could be like or or he could put him
just as like mini cameos and all the
movies that have come out since and we
never noticed some kind of a thing but
um yeah I always wondered what happened
to that guy when he was in that um
mobile commercial with Ryan Reynolds
recently I was like oh my God what did
happen to Rick Moranis do you want to
know
is there a story yeah oh no yeah his his
wife unfortunately passed away and so he
decided to quit acting so that he could
take care of his kids full time that's
freaking amazing oh well then we then we
definitely need this movie that yeah to
tell that story tell the story of what a
great tell us of what a great dude
person father he is and and then and
then you know if he wants to he could
come back then and you know like ride
the wave of success that he he still
deserves that would be great it actually
yeah like no I would love a Rick Moranis
biopic just like showing him and like
just basically like celebrating his wife
and like you know his family and yeah
yeah
and his family because his family is so
important to him I'm so I'm so sad I
never even heard of that but it has to
be funny because the weird Yankovic
story is funny you guys in my defense I
had no idea whatever
you're problematic
maybe Rick Moranis is gonna be like I'm
gonna look at the lighter side of things
and it could be again it could be about
something else again it could be about
him fighting crime and defeating the
Yakuza boom
none of that I want to see an action I
want to see bullet train starring Rick
Morales that's what I love I I do
co-sign that that'd be very funny as
someone that has seen the Weird Al's
story
um not to not to Shameless plug but he
retweeted me about it and I was the only
person at the premiere that he retweeted
wait wait Daniel Radcliffe or Weird Al
oh my God
I literally had a heart attack I posted
about it and I was like okay cool and I
looked through the retweets and it was
him and I was like no I can't believe
that I'm friends with someone that Weird
Al Yankovic
real quick homie let me look at this
yeah autograph
um you know what no
absolutely you guys don't deserve it
that's the last thing you little sick
twisted mind freaks deserve okay October
October 6 I said just watch Weird Al
Yankovic at Beyond Fest and never left
harder at something in my entire life it
was non-stop I can't wait to watch it a
million more times which I will the
movie is phenomenal you guys this is not
a this is a plug for weird it's so funny
it's so good it's so silly and so
freaking good you guys it's uh the
director and writer is the guy that
directed and wrote like every funny or
die sketch so you can only expect how
silly it can get either way I want the
same thing done for Keke Palmer and I
think it would be so funny to see that
Disney child at playing herself now
playing a 10 year old and going through
like the from like the jump rope movie
yes she already has a biopic it's called
a True Jackson VP have you not watched
it it's uh
um clearly none of you have seen Aquila
and the bee that's the true Bible okay
and then we go through her music keep it
moving uh her best single my favorite
single
um I just think Kiki Palmer would do
such a great story of herself no my
favorite of her works is when she
featured in push it to the Limit or by
Corbin Bleu [ __ ] you know that's my
second that's my second but keep it
moving keep it moving only the black
girls in 2003 that watch broke Theory
today will know that song
we can stand together rise up for Kiki
good night
okay keep over I dig it what do you
think Whitney okay so uh mine is a
biopic that I've basically already
almost started writing uh I do this
thing a lot where I will think of
someone that I just haven't heard about
or heard of in a while like Rick Moranis
uh someone who just disappeared from
public eye and I will go and obsessively
look up every single [ __ ] thing that
I can about that person and so I
recently did this with Eric Von Deton oh
my God who played Andy Brink Brinker and
Brink and he also played the uh the mean
boyfriend in The Princess Diaries and so
I looked him up because I was like he
was so good looking like what what
happened to him like he was like at his
prime as like a teen Hearts job in these
like Disney movies like why did he quit
so I found out
that he quit acting to join a venture
capital firm and I believe it's called
Uh Rosalind capital and it's a precious
metals uh asset management firm so what
they do is if you have gold you take
your gold to Andy Brink Brinker and Andy
Brink Brinker tells you how to manage
your gold and silver and other precious
metals and this is a true story and so I
want to know how the [ __ ] this guy went
from doing little skateboard flippy dues
to working at a at a precious metal
asset management company I have no idea
how that happened I need the full story
so that's my page that's what I think I
was confused but you know what like well
after watching Brink and knowing that
Brink's family was so poor
I'm I'm glad that he's working with gold
you know what I'm saying
to the Tangled he's
a lit Scrooge mcducking it just you know
swimming
no pants diving into a pile of money
exactly
but no like I loved like Eric like he I
loved brick so much like I I honestly am
shocked that he's like not a famous
actor to this day because like he's sort
of like no I don't know like he wasn't
like a Leonardo DiCaprio but like he
sort of like was like had that Vibe I
don't know he's like a very handsome kid
yeah he did he was like a handsome teen
he had that like Disney Teen like
heartthrob thing where like he could
have totally been in a bunch of other
like Princess Diaries
um yeah yeah
I wanna I wanna know the full Eric Von
Denton story that's my that's my word
biopic I'm gonna give that the Rogue
question winner medal of the day because
like I love Brinks so much I loved Eric
Von day yeah and I'm a child
so yes the Eric Von Denton story needs
to be told on Roku next please but I
loved all your theories and all of your
Amazing Ideas you guys are wonderful
people and I love talking with you guys
always you guys thank you for your time
I love talking to you guys you guys are
the best and you're so funny and cute
and sweet it's true I'm confirmed but
that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory thank you to our amazing guest
Justin Clemens Whitney van luntingham
and Tom Michaelson please go follow them
on all their social medias and support
them on whatever they do they're amazing
people if you support Jessica
Clements listen to keep it moving by
Kiki
is the best way to support Jessica
and be like Jessica Clement is still
listening to the damn Anthem and it's
like 14 years old remember to also tell
her that uh push it to the Limit by
Corbin Bleu is
superior.com you can follow me at Master
David on Twitter you can follow your
Rock shows on all our social platforms
and be sure to subscribe to our channel
here on YouTube see you guys next time
we love you guys be safe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]